jean marc sylvestre bonjour alors on va
essayer de regarder avec vous en détail
certaines propositions pas tout mais les
plus importantes pour commencer quel et
vous pensez de ce rapport écoutez j'ai
très cash je suis assez consterné un
papa par la démarche
abasourdis par les mesures et puis
inquiet peut-être par le débat politique
que ça va ça peut provoquer alors je
comprends le diagnostic c'est à vérifier
partagé par pratiquement tous les
experts scientifiques et plus par
l'ensemble de la population il existe un
problème grave sur le réchauffement
climatique et et tout le monde sait
c'est là aussi partager que les
activités humaines sont sans doute
responsable de ce risque là mais je
comprends pas comment on peut imaginer
que ça pouvait se régler de cette façon
c'est à dire 1 voix en groupe par la
contrainte parce que la démarche qui a
été initiée par emmanuel macron a été de
tirer au sort 150 français qui sont qui
serait représentatif de la population
française pour qu'ils réfléchissent à
des propositions de réformes en leur
disant que ces réformes seront
appliquées proposé à la ratification des
deux assemblées nationales alors mai
mais par conséquent je vois pas pourquoi
on ne passe pas directement par
l'assemblée nationale ou par le sénat
quelle est la légitimité de ce groupe
pour décider quelles réformes mais il
faut engager et il faut les imposer à
tout le monde alors le résultat vous le
disiez pour ma part est assez
consternant parce qu il faudra donc
obligatoirement par exemple rénover les
immeubles de façon à les isoler de façon
à économiser de l'énergie faudra changer
son alimentation
manger moins de viande moins de lait
mais plus de végétaux plus de poireaux
plus de carottes
il faudra intervenir aussi des centres
commerciaux de façon à réanimer les
centres villes dans les villes moyennes
et puis interdire la publicité
commerciale acheter des produits
durables qui soit réparable bref il
faudra aussi mois - voyage et pas ou peu
grande l'avion travailler moins réduire
la vitesse sur les autoroutes vous
disait alors 650 mesure qui produisent
des interdictions d obligations d
jonction et des pénalités fiscales et
puis surtout des beaucoup de règles
liberticide
alors on voit pas comment on peut sortir
de ce débat dans une démocratie qui a
fixé la liberté individuelle comme base
de fonctionnement alors jean marc est ce
qu'il y a dans cette convention dans
cette démarche un des intentions
politiques
alors il y avait des intentions
politiques de la part du président de la
république puisque c'est lui qui au
lendemain du mouvement des gilets jaunes
pour pouvoir répondre en quelque sorte à
cette demande de démocratie populaire
avait initié cette idée là mais il y à
deux coups du côté des 150 français qui
ont été tirés au sort
sans doute une démarche peut être
inconsciente d'ailleurs politiques
idéologiques radical dans la mesure où
ils ont été épaulés par un certain
nombre d'experts qui l'ont choisie ou
qui leur ont été imposés on ne sait pas
comment ça s'est passé puis aussi
beaucoup de juristes
il ya des contradictions tout ça qui
aboutissent à des choix qui sont des
choix moraux des choix idéologiques
première contradiction par exemple c'est
que les règles proposées sur liberticide
elles vont à l'encontre de la liberté
individuelle
elles s'inscrivent dans une écologie
punitive
si vous mangez de la viande vous êtes
coupable si vous disiez n'est pas votre
logement vous êtes coupable mais comment
peut-on imaginer obliger les gens à
isoler son logement
s'ils n'ont pas d'argent pour le faire
mais vous savez les gens qui ont de
l'argent ils s'isolent leur logement
parce qu'ils y voient des économies
d'énergie à faire non alors que tout ça
devrait s'inscrire dans un univers
incitateur c'est à dire revoir un navet
de la pédagogie du bon sens d'ailleurs
les gens les français ont conscience
qu'il ya un problème et sur prêts à
faire un nombre d'efforts naturellement
la deuxième tradition c'est que ces
règles ne s'attaque à la croissance
et ça c'est beaucoup plus rare elle
organise quelque part la décroissance on
produit moins on voyage juin on mange
moins
or la croissance est nécessaire pour
mieux vivre pour la santé le confinement
liés à la pandémie a été relativement
bien vécu par ceux qui en avaient les
moyens
mais quand même relativement mal parce
qu'ils avaient un petit logement et qui
ont perdu leur job ou qui ont perdu leur
entreprise donc la croissance là et est
indispensable
et bah de l'écologie est évidemment
nécessaire mais on n'y arrivera pas en
obligeant les gens je vous répète à
vivre autrement sinon on se retrouvera
avec une guerre civile avec des gilets
jaunes
d'ailleurs je crois savoir et samedi
après midi ça a quand même frotté fort
certains des 150 procès 11 sont traités
un peu de guignol de bus ils ont retiré
d'ailleurs à certain nombre de décisions
finalement travailler - par exemple ça a
été retiré au dernier moment on peut on
ne peut pas prendre les français pour
des enfants ou pour des gens qui sont
complètement inculte y sent responsable
et il faut donc inciter au changement su
frapper d'ailleurs je suis frappé
d'ailleurs que certaines entreprises
aient beaucoup de populations sont
conscients de 2,7 la rse par exemple la
responsabilité sociale environnementale
ça existe et ça marche dans beaucoup
d'entreprises et ça permet quoi ça
permet de satisfaire des clients
ça permet de satisfaire des salariés ça
permet de section des actionnaires de
compos aboutir à un compromis qui
protège la croissance merci beaucoup à
jean marc sylvestre d'avoir répondu à
mes questions je rappelle que vous êtes
éditorialistes écho à pic